This administration has made it very clear
they see vote by mail as an existential threat
to Donald Trump's reelection and to Republicans
winning in a whole bunch of different states.
And Donald Trump now isn't even playing coy
about it.
He is talking about it.
He's saying, oh, the fraud and vote by mail.
All of that stuff.
But now Trump is going to a new level.
Trump is straight up demanding that California
mail in ballots not be counted.
Just throw them in the trash.
My friends, previously here is Trump admitting
that vote by mail would mean many Republicans
don't win.
Remember, this is just the common facts.
I mean, they have a majority in the House
and therefore you need their vote and they
want to get certain things.
I will tell you this.
If you look at before and after the things
they had in there were crazy.
They had things, levels of voting that if
you ever agreed to it, you'd never have a
Republican elected in this country again.
They had things in there about, you know,
election days.
And what do you do if the more people that
vote, the worse you do.
That means there's something wrong with what
you're offering.
If you win only by holding down turnout and
suppressing the vote, that's a platform that
may not be so good for people.
And more and more states have decided in light
of the Corona virus pandemic, we've got to
vote by mail in 2020, at least November, we're
going to be voting by mail.
California just announced that Gov. Gavin
Newsom, by executive order said all voters,
all voters can and should vote by mail.
Trump doesn't want those votes counted.
Trump announced via a tweet that, quote, So
in California, the Democrats who fought like
crazy to get all mail in only ballots and
succeeded have just opened a voting booth
in the most Democrat area in the state.
They are trying to steal another election.
It's all rigged out there.
These votes.
Votes must not count.
Scam is democracy functioning when the president
says votes shouldn't count.
If they are mailed in or cast in a specific
precinct.
While we have states like Oregon where elections
are by default, vote by mail.
And remember, of course, that Donald Trump
himself votes by mail in his new legal residents
of Florida, which saves him a whole bunch
of money on taxes.
Here was Trump explaining that for him to
vote by mail is fine.
It's just not okay for other people to do
it.
So you were highly critical of mail in voting,
failing mail in ballots from mailing you anything.
Is your voting rights corrupt in Florida's
election last month?
Sure, I could vote by mail for that because
I'd love to.
Well, that's called out of state.
You know why I voted?
Because I happen to be in the White House
so they won't be able to go to Florida.
Look at me just nailing that.
Well, there's a big difference between somebody
that's out of state and does a ballot and
everything sealed, certified and everything
else.
You see what you have to do with the certifications
and you get thousands and thousands of people
sitting in somebodys living room signing ballots
all over the place.
No, I think that mail in voting is a terrible
thing.
I think if you vote, you should go.
And even the concept of early voting is not
the greatest because a lot of things happen.
But it's okay.
But you should go and you should vote.
I think you should go and you should vote.
You look at what they do, where they grab
thousands of mail in ballots and they dump
it.
Don't adjust your monitor or your speakers.
That actually makes as little sense as it
sounds like.
You're not mishearing that trump the hypocrite
once again.
And the things he's talking about, you know,
the fraud that has had.
And with Maylin stuff, it's been mostly Republicans
fraudulently collecting absentee ballots from
people and getting involved in funny business.
His entire.
I did it because I'm allowed to thing is completely
circular reasoning, because what Governor
Newsome has done is allowed people to vote
by mail.
By definition, that means they are allowed
to vote by mail, just like Trump is allowed
to vote by mail.
But of course, that's different in the world
of Trump.
Now, a few important notes about what California's
doing, because it's great.
And in fact, every state should be doing this.
Going into November.
California is not closing in-person voting.
They're discouraging it.
And they're sending every registered voter
an absentee ballot.
They did say they're going to keep some polling
places open and they've made a decision about
population distributions and where those polling
places should be.
But the sending everyone a ballot is huge
because in some states they're insisting on
the norm.
Normal protocol.
We'll send you an absentee ballot, but you've
got to request it.
And there are usually state laws or at least
guidelines that say you can't just send people
absentee ballots.
They have to request them.
Clearly, these are extenuating circumstances.
And as I said a couple of weeks ago, governors
can deal with this exactly the way Gavin Newsom
is dealing with it, which is by saying via
executive order, this time I am determining
I am, I am.
I have decided, given the circumstances, we
will send everybody an absentee ballot, even
if they don't requested.
Very simple to get around.
It hasn't happened didn't happen in Ohio in
advance of their mail in election.
But California is doing it.
It's the right thing to do.
Trump is panicking.
Republicans are panic, panicking, and we know
exactly why.
We'll have continued coverage of this on the
show's Instagram page.
David Pakman show on Instagram.
You can find clips and means and polls and
all sorts of stuff while you are there.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
Major news in my urban garden.
My cucumbers have sprouted.
Ladies and gentlemen and I will have continued
coverage from the front lines of my backyard
garden a very, very soon